the imf's projections for the world
economy have worsened significantly
since its last report in january when it
predicted a post-pandemic recovery the
reason is clear global economic
prospects have been severely set back
largely because of russia's invasion of
ukraine
this crisis unfolds as the global
economy has not yet fully recovered from
the pandemic from an estimated 6.1
percent in 2021 the imf now says
economic growth will shrink to 3.6
percent in 2022 and 2023 the fund says
that inflation already surging due to
the pandemic will be amplified due to
war-related supply shortages and its
world economic outlook says increases in
food and fuel prices could lead to
social unrest
however the imf also said inflation for
advanced economies may fall to 2.5
percent next year some economists say
that should mean a change in course to
prevent a devastating global recession
uh threatening to do what it's done many
times before which is to increase
interest rates unnecessarily and that
affects the whole world because interest
rates of other central banks tend to
follow the fed in the world
and that makes it more difficult uh for
developing countries to avoid crises
economic crises that push millions of
people into poverty but such is the
uncertainty about the war in ukraine
further energy sanctions on russia
future deadly covert variants and more
supply bottlenecks in china the imf says
its latest predictions may be too
optimistic
to coincide with the imf spring meetings
oxfam has released a study predicting
that the pandemic and the war in ukraine
could push more than 263 million people
into extreme poverty in 2022 the
charities calling on the imf to stop
increasing hardship due to its
insistence on conditioning loans to the
developing world on implementing
austerity policies while it warns rich
nations to avoid cutting spending to
preserve what economic recovery there is
has said that uh that
the suffocating of a force of austerity
should not be in europe
uh but but we don't see the same in
developing countries and in poorer
countries oxfam says there's a
disconnect between the imf's research
which discusses increased social unrest
and more hunger because of the pandemic
and the war and the imf's actual policy
prescriptions for the most needy nations
which demand the slashing of the social
safety net ending subsidies on cooking
gas increasing taxes on food and
freezing public sector pay
shia britancy al jazeera washington